départ à l'attaqué des banques ont évité
les parents débarquent en d4 les matons
éclat débarrassa des cadres sera
platanes ou le garage de mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
mec j'ai trop faim depuis qu'on est dans
public à je vais prendre un kebab sens
blanche avec des tripes et non tu
trompes c'est quoi le vendeur de kebabs
mais c'est le présentateur c'est lui
larnack la série le plus grand des
acteurs mais les pas perdre tu feras pas
grand chose j'te ferai pas de flair même
site à la tête d'un vendeur de roses
radio twitter télé était partout c'est
fatigant pour faire tout ça tu engagé
quoi un sosie du pakistan tu fais de la
télé alors t'es pas présentables
tellement voix lui que les rasoirs se
cassait sa larve il se prend pour une
star depuis qu'il fait du cinéma il a
joué dans le dernier star wars chewbacca
luna trop de maquillage
vous êtes tous orange ou jaune mon petit
coup des fans qui pensent qu'ils
regardent les simpson maintenant et
franchement c'est trop tard
et franchement gros tas - de couilles
kenora businessman il est jamais dans la
dèche les tékés aparté pmp il vend des
babouches à marrakech nous fait croire
que tu es comme nous mais ça me fatigue
j'te vu dans l'hôtel cinq étoiles juste
en face de notre camping et on repart à
l'attaqué n'est pas qu'on évitait les
ballons des parcs ont extrait les maths
en éclats des barrages avec un de ses
rares la new look à la chorale de mike
n'ont fait vrai qu'on arrête parce que
comme tout le monde on regarde
l'émission le soir en cash et en berne
et des mythos est parce qu on est juste
des poteaux les personnes nous croient
chez nous cyril on peut prendre une
photo
c'est quoi le paris paris tu viens au
zénith
si je gagne tu viens aux états le 9 mars
et 9 pas par contre si je gagne ouais je
peux vous appeler n'importe quel
m'emmener dans l'émission allez hockey
quand il veut moi je suis chaud hier les
ciseaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier une feuille de papier vous allez
voir la pierre en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas par quels moyens je serai le
9 janvier à toulouse albi clown on est
dans la merde
non mais je vous le dis il y aura en
prime on sait pas quand mais il y aura
marre y aura 900 wii à la chaîne ne le
sait pas mais voilà ils sont anna cela
c'est nouveau
[Musique]
comment ça va les chéris ouais tu
m'entends très haut là on vient de vous
passer là vous nous regardez
ouais je sais je te regarde je vous
kiffe et ferrero ça va mais seriez vous
êtes pire que moi c'est un truc de ouf
les médiatrices on vous aime toi en
décalant sénégalais aurait juste samedi
sont pas des chérie je vous fais des
gros bisous à vous m
et tout le monde vous aime ici il ya une
mauvaise nouvelle bien battus de
lambeaux qui vous embrasse à merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]